Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je vais vous parler
d’un produit improbable,
le genre de produit
qui ne devrait pas exister,
le genre de produit [qui fait] que si vous
allez chez un investisseur, un banquier
ou un partenaire, il vous traite de fou.
Imaginez juste une seconde être
dans une très vieille ferme en Suisse.
Nous sommes entre Zurich et Saint-Gall,
au milieu - ça s’appelle Toggenburg.
Nous sommes à mille mètres d’altitude.
Une ferme qui a été vide
pendant 75 ans, 80 ans.
Il n'y a que des enfants qui jouent
de temps en temps dedans.
C’est un endroit où il y a environ
40 personnes qui vivent -
le village à côté.
Le postier, il ouvre l’Office -
quand il se sent bien.
S’il a mal à la tête, il n’ouvre pas,
il n’y a pas de courrier.
Imaginez un endroit pareil.
Et là, on va faire du saumon fumé.
Donc -
Eh oui.
(Rires)
Il s’appelait Hans Gerd Kübel,
grand acteur de théâtre allemand.
Vivant à Zurich, il a décidé un jour :
« J’ai besoin d’acheter une ferme,
ailleurs, et de faire du foin -
je ne sais pas si vous imaginez -
cueilli à la main,
pour le vendre au zoo de Zurich. »
Il a aussi pris des chiens japonais
qu’il a croisés avec des chiens allemands.
Je ne sais pas ce que c’est comme race,
mais c’était aussi son idée
de vendre des produits comme ça.
Juste avant de commencer, il est à Berlin,
il est en train de faire une tournée -
je crois que c’était « Marquis de Sade » -
il rencontre un monsieur,
qui s’appelle Kaplan, qui lui dit :
« Moi, je sais faire des fours
pour fumer du saumon, »
en fait, pour fumer des poissons.
[Kübel répond] : « Je viens
d’acheter cette ferme à Toggenburg,
Est-ce que vous pouvez le faire là-bas ?
- Oui, oui, pourquoi pas ? »
Ce qu’il oublie de lui dire,
c’est que, quand il construit des fours,
ce sont sur des fours pour 200 poissons,
pas pour un ou deux.
Et donc ce monsieur, il se retrouve
avec des fours six mois plus tard
dans lesquels, pour avoir un poisson pour
lui, il fallait qu’il en produise 200.
(Rires)
Pas génial.
Il y a perdu passablement de l’argent.
À ce moment-là, il revient
vers M. Kaplan et lui dit :
« Écoutez, je perds de l’argent.
Je ne peux pas produire 200 saumons
pour en avoir un pour moi,
donc il faut que j’arrête. »
Kaplan lui répond : « Mais,
vous ne m’aviez pas dit
que vous vouliez gagner de l’argent.
Dans la vieille Russie,
on pêchait les esturgeons
dans la mer Caspienne.
Ils ressortaient le dos de l’esturgeon
On appelait ça « balyk » - B A L Y K.
Faites ça avec du saumon,
vous allez voir. »
Alors, Kübel a fait ça avec du saumon,
il a eu un succès extraordinaire.
Mais finalement,
ce n’était pas vraiment son truc.
C’était un grand foodie,
c’était un grand gastronome,
mais ce n’était pas quelqu’un
qui voulait gérer une entreprise.
Et là, moi, j’arrive.
J’ai 26 ans.
Je rencontre M. Kübel,
je rencontre son partenaire, M. Klöti.
Je trouve l’idée pas mal de faire
du saumon dans les Alpes suisses.
Donc j’appelle mes parents,
je leur dis : « J’ai une idée. »
Mon père me dit : « Tu es né à Copenhague,
il y a de la mer autour,
là, il y a du poisson.
Normalement, on le sort
de la mer et on le fume.
Et toi, tu as eu l’idée brillante
d’amener ça dans les Alpes suisses. »
(Rires)
À ce moment-là, il regarde ma mère.
Il voit très bien - c’est très clair -
que c’est son fils à elle.
(Rires)
La même année, j’avais fait
une autre connerie.
Parce que ma grande passion dans la vie,
en dehors de la bouffe, c’est la musique.
Et en 84 ou 85,
il y a le premier système logiciel, qui
vient de la société qui s’appelle Atari,
où on peut jouer une note ou des mélodies
et ça imprime les partitions.
Aujourd’hui, c’est très courant,
mais en 84 ou 85,
c’était tout sauf courant,
c’était une véritable révolution,
surtout pour quelqu’un comme moi
qui ne sais pas lire la musique.
Donc je me suis dit :
« Puisque je vais faire
du saumon dans les Alpes
je peux aussi faire
un concert symphonique. »
(Rires)
Et donc j’ai écrit une symphonie.
Je ne sais pas la lire,
donc je ne suis pas sûr -
Vous imaginez, vous écrivez un livre,
mais n’arrivez pas à dire
s’il est correct ou pas.
(Rires)
Ça peut faire un peu tache.
Je me suis demandé :
« Comment est-ce que je peux voir
si ce que j’ai fait est juste ? »
Il faut un orchestre.
À Genève, il n’y a pas beaucoup
d’orchestres, il y en a un :
l’Orchestre Suisse Romande.
J’appelle quelqu’un qui appelle
quelqu’un qui appelle quelqu’un,
et finalement, j’ai réussi à louer
l’Orchestre Suisse Romande pour un jour
(Rires)
pour jouer ma symphonie.
Sauf que je n’avais pas compris
l’importance d’un chef d’orchestre.
(Rires)
Donc, j’arrive ce jour-là,
Il y a 65 musiciens
dans la salle Ansermet à Genève
et ils me demandent :
« Qui va nous diriger ?
(Rires)
- Ben... (Souffle) moi !
- Très bien. Votre bâton ?
- Je n’en ai pas, mais on peut prendre
une fourchette à la cantine.
Ça me va très bien. J’aime la bouffe. »
Ce que je ne savais pas,
puisque ce logiciel avait pris
les partitions que j’avais écrites,
que j’avais jouées,
il l’a fait à sa sauce.
La partie pour les violons
est allée chez les flûtes,
la partie de flûtes chez le trombone,
le trombone est allé partout.
Vous savez,
quand on écrit pour un orchestre,
il faut savoir comment le violon joue,
il faut savoir que les gens respirent.
Moi, je ne savais rien de ça.
Donc je suis là avec ma fourchette.
Personne dans la salle, sauf ma mère,
puisque j’ai invité ma mère -
c’est ma première symphonie,
il faut quand même que ma mère l’entende.
(Rires)
Le son -
C’est difficile de vous exprimer
la cacophonie qui est arrivée.
(Rires)
En tout cas, c’était -
Je n’avais jamais entendu quelque
chose d’aussi horrible de ma vie.
(Rires)
Mais vraiment.
Le premier violon de l’orchestre
vient vers moi : « Monsieur,
cette œuvre, c’est pour quoi faire ?
Pour un film ? Une publicité ? »
J’étais tellement choqué
par cette cacophonie, cet horrible son,
et ma propre audace, que je lui ai dit :
« Écoutez, c’est pour mon répondeur
téléphonique à la maison. »
(Rires)
Cinq ans après - je reviens au saumon.
Cinq ans après, j’ai un déjeuner avec
le responsable du tourisme à Genève,
et Claude Nobs,
le fondateur du Montreux Jazz.
On parle des gens bizarres.
(Rires)
À Genève, il y a beaucoup
de gens bizarres.
Claude Miffon dit : « Oui, vous savez,
il y a même un mec qui a loué
l’Orchestre Suisse Romande
pour son répondeur téléphonique. »
(Rires)
Et moi : « Non ? »
Mais ce que je veux dire par là,
c’est que, quand on décide de faire
du saumon fumé dans les Alpes suisses,
ça devient une véritable œuvre de vie.
On rêve, on s’imagine,
et il faut beaucoup de persévérance
pour y arriver.
J’ai eu la chance,
dix ans après, d’enregistrer
avec le London Symphony Orchestra
à Londres,
et je vous promets,
ça s’est très, très bien passé.
J’ai eu beaucoup de chance de voir
cette aventure avec le saumon fumé
prendre un chemin énorme.
La Suisse, ce n’est pas
un pays pour le poisson,
la Suisse, surtout la Suisse alémanique
profonde, c’est un pays de viande,
et néanmoins on a réussi à créer
quelque chose de très particulier.
Vous voyez, c’est idyllique,
ce n’est plus la vieille ferme,
les ruines que c’était avant.
Aujourd’hui, non seulement
on produit du saumon fumé,
mais on a aussi
un studio d’enregistrement.
(Rires)
Je mets les deux choses ensemble
et j’appelle ça
ma maison d’irresponsabilité.
(Rires)
En fait, ce sont mes deux passions.
Je suis arrivé à mettre la bouffe
et la musique dans la même maison.
Il n’y a pas vraiment
de leçon à prendre ici.
Je n’ai pas de leçon à vous donner.
Ce ne sont pas des idées
que je vous donne.
S’il vous plaît, n’allez pas fumer
du saumon dans les alpages suisses !
Je sais qu’on est là pour donner
des idées et les faire circuler.
Ce n’est pas ça du tout.
Si je peux en tirer quelque chose,
c’est de dire :
même quand ça a l’air improbable,
quand ça a l’air impossible,
il faut le faire quand même.
(Rires)
Parce que de temps en temps, ça marche.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)